we're going to look at an example of
property based testing I'm going to show
quick check which is tools I work with
and the idea here is you want to test
software and that's very important to
get software right but thinking of all
of the cases that you want to test is
not something that is very popular with
software developers actually and so uh
it's often not really done as thoroughly
as you would like and what I'm going to
show you is a tool that we can use for
generating tests so that instead of
running maybe you know a few dozen tests
that you make up by hand we can run
hundreds of thousands or millions and
get much more confidence that the
software really behaves the way that we
wanted to
example which is going to test that text
message encoding so this is actually a
part of the 2g telephony standard so
it's got old but the people who
introduced text messaging they were just
making use of some spare bits that
within the packages and they wanted to
fit as many characters as they could
into a text message and there was only
fill in space so they realized that they
only needed 7 bits per character and so
that's what they decided to use but when
you put those 7 bit characters into the
messages you have to fit them into 8-bit
bytes and that means that you can fit
eight characters into seven bytes so of
course the standard says you must do
that and that means the way you have a
message you want to send you have to
encode it by packing the bits closer
together and when you receive it you
have to decode it and here I've got some
code that came from a company in France
that does that encoding and decoding so
let me just start by showing the code
that we got so here it is this is
airline code and this is the code for
packing characters you can see there's
plenty of it this is the code for
unpacking them again and there's plenty
of that and we're not going to look in
detail at this the only thing I want to
point out is that there's a lot of code
and it's complex so it's quite easy to
imagine that there might be an error in
there so of course we need to test that
and down here we have some test code and
what it does is it says well let's just
take a sample message let's try packing
it and then unpacking it and what it
will call that T and at the end of the
day what we get after unpacking must be
the same as the message to be started
off with and then there's a little test
suite here that says just try that for a
number of different strings and
somebody's thought about this a little
bit and they've tried all length of
message from 0 to 10 so yeah hopefully
if it works with these strings that
it'll work in general so what we can do
now is just compile that program so just
done and now I can run that test code if
I do so then we get some output all of
the text that's good it seems to work
but of course what always down straight
is it works for these particular ten
strings so you might wonder if we give
it some other message
is there a risk that the code won't
actually work as we expect so that gives
us a chance to use a test generation
tool and when we use quick check I go
back to the code here I actually have
what we call it quick check property
this is the way that we write test code
with property based testing we like
something that's supposed to be true in
general of our code here I'm saying for
all messages all messages not just
pretend that tests which are lists of
7bit values so they're made up of seven
MIT characters then if I pack that
message and unpack it I should get the
message I started off with so that says
the same thing as the tester I had
before but it says it's in general and
that means that now I can use quick
check to generate as many tests as I
like and make sure that code still works
so let me go back to my test execution
window here and I will just use quick
check I'll call it and I'll give it that
properties that I just showed you as an
argument and we'll see what happens whoa
after only a little more than 100 tests
quick check found an example in which
the property doesn't hold of what you
see here is first of all a randomly
generated message it's a sequence of
bytes which appears numbers here you can
think of it as a message and that
message was not packed and unpacked
correctly so after finding a random
example like this quick check goes on to
simplify the failing case as much as it
can and we end up with this message
which is just eight zeros so why does
quick checks say the problem occurs with
h0 and not for example seven zeros well
because if you have seven zeros the code
works right so this is the smallest
example that doesn't work and if I run
quit again you'll see that it starts off
finding a different random example but
when it simplifies the test case we get
the same eight zeros this is one of the
key things about this kind of property
based testing you always get the
simplest case and because you know it's
the simplest that tells you a lot about
what the problem might be
okay so so it's easily something to do
with being 8 characters long so maybe it
works for all other lengths so what I
can do is I can investigate when the
code fails now by changing my property
so if I go back to the property I had
here at the moment it says for every
list of seven that bytes packing
unpacking gives you the same result now
I'm going to add an implication I'm
going to say for every list of 7bit
bytes provided the length of the message
is not 8 then it should work so my
hypothesis is that the length of 8
characters is the problem so let's just
test now messages of other lengths if I
do that I'll just recompile my test code
and rerun quick check now 2000 tests
passed so maybe I was right I'll just
run a few more tests which I can do by
running tests for let's say 10 seconds
there we are
oh it still doesn't work so now we find
another example where packing and
unpacking failed this is actually
consists of 16 zeros so maybe it's not
just being of length 8 that matters
maybe any multiple of 8 is also a case
that I fail but let's investigate that I
can go back to my property and I can
change it to say that provided the
length is not a multiple of 8 that's
what that means then packing and
unpacking the message should give me the
same result back and if I we compile
that and run the test again now quick
check is discarding some tests that's
what the cross is mean so running lost
test every dot as a passing test or by
now every dot was 10,000 passing tests
the crosses are tests that we're a
multiple of eight quick check is not
sound of failing case after 185,000
tests so that suggests that we're right
but as long as the length isn't a
multiple of eight then code works but I
can also investigate the problem more
closely I know when the test when the
message is a multiple of eight then the
code sometimes fails but doesn't always
fail well let me go back to my
property and I'll just take that out or
true then said which does nothing
instead of generating any letters as a
message I'll just generate lists of
length 8 and I'm focusing testing on the
case on suspicious off is every message
of mint age coded rolling let's find out
I'll run these tests so that entry
message has length 8 and what do you
know some of them past 38 test passed
obviously many things are correctly
encoded but this example is not an
Laura's this example now I want to look
at the random example that fails and
it's just a few more of them one of the
nice things about generating tests as
you can see a lot of different examples
of the same thing so is there anything
in common between that first example
this other one you can see that's full
of different values of numbers those are
all different but oh wait a minute look
at our last number there and the last
one here last one here they all end in 0
that's very unlikely to happen by chance
so maybe the code works unless the
message is a multiple of 8 in length and
the last character is 0 let's test that
hypothesis I'll just change this still
to run tests you've lens a but to say
provided the last character of the
message is not 0 then the code should
work okay so am i writing my hypothesis
let's find out woo now all of the tests
are passing and after 10 seconds we will
see we run 222,000 tests without a 0 in
the last position they all passed so
that strong evidence that the hypothesis
was right ok so now without even looking
at that complicated code we understand
the problem very well we know it happens
when the message is a multiple of 8 we
know that it happens when the last
character is 0 and if we think about it
we can actually understand why this is
happening when we pack a number of
characters into bytes they're always
going to be some bits left over what
happens if
pack seven characters into seven bytes
what happens is that there are seven
bits left over seven zero bits that
looks very like eight characters where
the last one is zero and that's the
problem it's a problem in the standard
it can't distinguish between a message
that contains eight characters with a
zero at the end as a message that just
contains the first seven and it's a
known problem so there's no way around
it except I suggest not putting zero
characters in your messages we realized
that we were all working with very much
the same kind of programming language
but because we each had our own compiler
we couldn't share any code we couldn't
share our results and that just seemed
like a waste of effort so that led to
the proposal to just take the Common
Core of what we're all doing